Speaker 1: Vermont Senator Bernie Sanders, you
know him. You love him. He is not giving up on
build back better just because Joe Manchin is
giving up on it. And in fact, Bernie is ready
to bring the fight to Joe Manchin and bring
it to Manchin's home state of West Virginia.
I think it's easy for some of us to say, Well,
look, we have a 50-50 Senate right now and shucks,
what are we going to do? You have this split
control and Democrats, we're not going to get
everything that we want because you have to appeal
to the most conservative members of the party,
like your Joe Manchin and your Kirsten cinemas.
So ultimately, we'll get some stuff that we want,
but not everything. Well, Bernie is just saying,
I'm not going to take that approach. I'm going to
stand in the way here, and I'm going to
do so by making sure that West Virginia
voters know exactly why they can't get all
of these different favorable provisions,
like the child tax credit and the elder and child
care and universal preschool and so much more.
And they can't get all that stuff because of their
own senator Democrat Joe Manchin. Bernie went on
CNN's State of the Union this week with Jake
Tapper. And he proposed the idea of CNN paying
for a poll asking residents what they think
of all the different components of build back
better. And then as he thought about it, he said,
You know what? Screw it, I'm going to pay for the
damn poll. Let's take a look at the video.
Speaker 2: If Senator Manchin were here,
he would say, My state is a state that voted
overwhelmingly for Donald Trump. What I'm doing
and going after and opposing this legislation
will be popular, and Manchin has said he thinks of
all this money. He's saying all this money is
going to mean that she is going to make inflation
worse. Look, I talked about let me talk about
Joe Manchin voted for a huge increase in military
spending. Manchin voted for an infrastructure bill
which added two hundred and fifty billion dollars
to the deficit. The truth of the matter is that
if you look at the military budget 770 billion
times that by 10 years, it is four times
higher than what the build back better plan is
now. You know, Mr. Manchin says he's
representing the people of West Virginia. OK,
why don't you do a poll at CNN? Do a poll and you
ask the people of West Virginia whether or not
they want to lower the cost of prescription drugs?
You ask them whether they want to expand Medicare
to cover dental hearing and eyeglasses. You ask
whether they want to continue the $300 payment
to help working parents in these very difficult
times bring up their kids with dignity.
Ask them if they want to deal with climate
change on all of those issues. I suspect
people of West Virginia, like every other state in
this country, will say yes, do the right thing for
working families is there. And our challenge?
You know, I called Mantia, by the way. I'll
pay for the damn poll in West Virginia on those
issues. See how the people of West Virginia feel.
Speaker 1: I like that. So Bernie Sanders, he
wrote the damn bill having to do with Medicare for
all. And now he'll pay for the damn poll, having
to do with build back better. So Bernie is really
getting assertive there. And of course, Bernie
is right now. If you asked voters in conservative
Trump supporting West Virginia, do you support
Joe Biden's $1.9 trillion social spending plan?
You're probably not going to get favorable
results. I doubt you'd get 50 percent support.
Just being honest there, that's the reality. But
like what Bernie points out, if you go provision
by provision and you ask people, Do you support
lowering prescription drug prices? Do you support
expanding Medicare? Do you support a child
tax credit and all of these different things?
Of course, people are going to say yes to
all of those different things because they
are indeed popular. And it doesn't matter
whether you ask people in liberal California
or conservative West Virginia, people are going to
say that they, like all of that different stuff.
This is, by the way, exactly what we saw when it
came to the Affordable Care Act two years ago.
If you pull people back then and you said, OK,
do you want people, young people to be able to
stay on their parents health care coverage
until they turn 26? People would say yes. If
you asked people whether or not they think that
businesses with more than 50 employees should
be able to, should, should have to offer health
insurance to their workers. People would say yes.
And if you ask people whether or not they think
that health insurance companies should be able to
deny coverage to discriminate based on preexisting
conditions, people would say no. But then if you
said, OK, well, do you support Obamacare? People
would say, No, I don't. Perhaps not realizing
that the ACA did all of those different things. So
Bernie is exactly right here that a poll conducted
in West Virginia on all of the different build
back, better provisions. It would probably do
really well there, but it, of course, depends on
how you ask the questions. And this is also not
the first time that Bernie has tried to pressure
Joe Manchin in this way, and it's not even the
first time that he's tried to do it on build back
better. Specifically, a couple of months ago,
Bernie wrote an op ed in the Charleston Gazette
Mail, which is a West Virginia based newspaper,
and he argued for the social spending bill, which
back then was actually more like $3 trillion.
It's a lot smaller now because Democrats caved
to the most conservative members of their party
like Manchin Cinema, and they reduced it by
about a trillion dollars. At the time, it was
a lot bigger. And it seems like Bernie writing
that op ed really got under Joe Manchin skin.
And you said it was because while we have this out
of state are telling us what we should do here in
West Virginia. But I think it really, truly got
under Joe Manchin skin because he knew that Bernie
Sanders was right here and this is what we got to
do. This is playing hardball and it's exactly what
Bernie should be doing. Biden should be doing
the exact same thing. Do some speeches in
West Virginia meet with people there? Talk
about how build back better would materially
improve their lives. Get on the phone with
Joe Manchin office. Obviously, you keep it
respectful and you give Manchin the room to
change his mind with some dignity, but make
it clear that his job security could be put at
risk if he decides not to support the legislation